[Musik]
etwas gedacht und jetzt willkommen beim
ein video
ja ich bin mal gespannt was jetzt dazu
denkt ob ich noch zu hause bin oder
nicht
ich glaube eher nicht so also verhindert
und biegsamer noch relativ gleich aus
aber ich bin nicht mehr 20 bin jetzt
nach köln gezogen und trainer tier in
meiner ersten wohnung die so in meinem
leben mir gehört damit meine kindheit
hinter mir gelassen und start in ein
neues leben voller zuversicht und ein
stündchen klubs nicht alle könnte sein
dass ein wenig halt wir haben wir uns
dann mehr großen studio gebaut wo ich
jetzt in zukunft immer aufnehmen werde
aber ein richtiges 20 viel zu sagen
meine haare und währenddessen anders die
sind noch nach das liegt daran
ansonsten habe ich ihn bis die
halsschmerzen ich weiß nicht warum habe
ich einfach irgendwie so alles dazu aber
es ist auf dem weg der besserung auf
jeden fall und ich habe mich hingesetzt
und habe mir gedacht es kommt wird sich
hin weil ich mich hingesetzt mehr als
ich mir für das heutige video folgen zu
überlegen und war gibt es glaube ich so
dinge die nur mädchen verstehen und dann
gibt es auch dinge die nur jungs
verstehen also so ganz verschiedene
situationen und ich habe mich da man
sich schlau gemacht ich hab ein bisschen
selber überlegt und hab euch auch auf
plötzlich gefragt und da kann man
erstmal ganz vielen von euch mädchen und
deswegen jetzt dem heutigen video darum
den mädchen machen voran als es ihrem
zehn dinge die will ich nur mädchen
verstehen wohl günstig zu denken hey was
meint sie keine ahnung wo das gleich
gibt's natürlich auch noch als film
dinge die jungs verstehen in der woche
oder so keine ahnung wenn ihr junge
seite könnte meinen kommentaren steigen
was verstehen oder jung auch wenn ich
das selber schon ziemlich viele sachen
aber mich hat das erstmal interessiert
was denn nicht nur mädchen verstehen und
zu teuer das quartier aufschlagen wollte
wenn ihr bock habt auf seine riesen xxl
future in der woche oder so der gast
einfach meinen daumen nach oben da ich
würde sagen weil wild verleihen
[Musik]
dass mein mitbewohner bei 13.500 like
gibt es die existenz solcher locker drin
sein längst mal und jetzt fangen
ach so schaut's euch auf jeden fall auch
mein letztes video an das haben wir
nicht so viele gesehen leider aber das
ist ja cool geboren ist ganz oben die
bestellung verlängern du fühlst dich
anschauen auf einen ganz bestimmten
grund zurück
das wird mich wirklich also eigentlich
wollte das nicht mit rein hin weil das
ist einfach nur ein vorurteil oder das
ist total aufgelöst aber ihr habt jetzt
wirklich ohne befall locker 200 mal
geschrieben kann von irgendwem von euch
übers netz reingeflogen und zwar nur
mädchen verstehen warum nie zu zweit
aufs klo gehen dabei um sich zu
unterhalten um über jungs zu letzteren
über stadelmann weil ich mich aber das
wollte schon mal sagen diesem punkt habe
ich der aufgelesen arbeit volk inhalt
nicht mit rein nehmen selbst denkt nicht
nur alex du hast mein ding übersehen
ich hab mich übersehen punkt nummer zwei
wir haben in unserer tasche die
unnötigsten dinge und wenn jung das
sehen fragen die immer wofür aber die
würden es nie verstehen
du sagtest alt und hat in einer tasche
die ungewöhnlichsten dinge als mädchen
warum habe ich eine andere als in meiner
tasche gehabt
statt in die kommentare ich habe ich
wirklich gedacht das habe ich auch öfter
gelesen und auch nur ungefähr in der
gleichen ausdrucksweise der moment wenn
du weißt seine freundin hat ihre tage
linie und durch die 0 0 anschauen weil
du ja den flow geführt
es ist ein mädchen unsere tage haben und
diesen dann kommt es mal fordert beim
niesen eine ganze ladung ein blutdruck
und er halt nur natürlich wenn aber das
wollte ich jetzt auch gar nicht so
unbedingt im detail witten aber weiß
dass viele von euch geschrieben haben
habe ich mir nicht nehmen lassen und das
auch mit reingenommen
das heißt verstehen ist immer wenn ein
mädchen ist in floh
stellt euch vor ich bin mädchen hatte
ihr brüste die haben den song gespielt
nur mädchen verstehen dass man sich
unter mädchen lieb hat oder sich umarmt
wieso man kann zur unter jungs lief
haben kann für kurzen krieg geben
hier handle sich um armen bin ich okay
du hast recht es versteht man echt mich
also wenn ich was sind die orte als wenn
mich jetzt ein guter freund von mir
fragen würde ja alle kannst mir nicht
mehr eine umarmung geben
mit dem schon um abend geben es stimmt
schon so richtet die kamera schießt
sowie machen weiter
die phillies hat mir geschrieben also
das ist jetzt eine konversation sieht
man was weiß ich lauf noch vor
alles lief das soll nur mädchen
verstehen und ich habe ich keine ahnung
was gemeint wildmann was können wir
vielleicht dafür stehen dass die
freundin eine hohe sahen hat die
vielleicht ein bisschen durchsichtig ist
und nicht möchte dass man in die
unterhose liederer wirkt aber was
anderes ist mir das jetzt echt nicht
eingefallen erklärt sich dann aber bitte
in den kommentaren darüber auch danke so
die nächste sache hat ein junges team
und da dachte ich du hast recht und zwar
wegen der sache was ein mädchen
verstehen
ich bin zwar kein aber ich glaube dass
wenn jemand dasselbe anhatte wie ein
anderes mädchen jungs würden ja sagen
deine sachen oder so aber mädels haben
dann immer voll den hauttyp da hast du
glaub ich voll recht klar ihr könnt
jetzt auch in die kommentare schreiben
das ist nicht so wir sind cool wenn so
freuen dass gleich analysiert aber ich
glaube dass den jungen bitte noch kreis
mädchen junge möglich war kann wegmann
kosten
boah jungs verstehe nicht warum mädchen
im kino beiden mittel ohne biss verstehe
ich nicht ich habe ehrlich noch nie sind
fechten harte typen
es kommt nicht vieles so einfach an mich
ran heute ist echt viel scheiße aber auf
jeden fall
ich hab noch nie im kino gewalt und ich
verstehe nicht wie man wein kann ich
meine das ist nur ein film
das ist auch in echt restaurant das habe
ich immer im hinterkopf und dann sah ich
etwas aus dass nur ein film ok wen sagt
alles die abkürzung mhf ich war ein mfh
wohlig rip tore habe ich auch wirklich
werte auch bekommen ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass wir nicht in ihre hose
oder ihre lektion zu weit nach oben
ziehen und man dann so den groben
umrisse des weitesten was konkreter mich
jetzt gemeinsam will ich gar nicht
weiter darauf eingehen ich könnte mir da
jetzt was vorstellen aber das klappt
manchmal so ihr könnt ihr meine
kommentare schreiben was ihr dazu denkt
oder was genau gemeint ist formuliert es
bitte nicht ganz aus ist mir scheiß egal
ob es könnte aus kombiniert eine ganz
kurze information am pult zweiten
abschnitt ein kleines zuschauer treffen
im centro oberhausen vorstellen kommt
ein rundes kostenlos bis 17 uhr
wir sehen uns nicht länger bocken ist so
furchtbar fühlt sich das video hat
unterhalten wie gesagt bei 13.500 gibt
die xxl future und schaut euch auf jeden
fall ein nettes video an
das kann ich euch meinen verträgen ganz
oben in der video beschreibung verlinkt
und wir sehen uns morgen wieder morgen
um 8 oder 9 10 uhr kommt ein richtig
geiles video freitag auch sonntag auch
ich nenne die aktive hat 100 m strecke
mit dem umzug ist immer noch ziemlich
plötzlich war noch sehr sehr viele
sachen fehlen ja bekannt auf jeden fall
gespannt sein auf die hohen tour das
geht direkt dann richtig richtig geile
raum und dann auch noch unser zimmer und
sucht und er wollte nicht sagen
kathrein folgt mehr ins netz und musiker
leben kamen
diese gerät online und ich noch voll
diverser ist aber schluss